ليس وحده من انه الم في اليمن ثم تاخرون
كثر يفتك بهم المرض والجوع
يتلقى الطفل الصقر محمد ذو الاربع سنوات
العلاج اسبوعيا بمركز رعايه الاطفال في
مدينه عدن املا في البقاء على قيد الحياه
يعاني التقزم بسبب سوء التغذيه يعقو ذلك
النمو البدنيه والعقليه ويتهدد مستقبله
[موسيقى]
الدكتوره اروى
المنظمات الدوليه من ان اعداد الاطفال
المصابين بالتقزم في ارتفاع مستمر من
اعراض التقزم قصر القامه والزراعين
والساقين انهيك عن ضمور العضلات تقف الاسر
في اليمن عاجزه عن مواجهه هذا الوضع
ادعوزها القدره على تلبيه متطلبات الحياه
فكيف بنفقات العلاج والاستشفاء في بلد
تدهور فيه القطاع الصحي ودمرت نصف بنيته
الاستشفائيه جراء الحرب المستمره منذ
سنوات
في فتره النمو عندها سوء تغذيه يحصل عندها
نوع من التقدم فدي فعلا الحالات انه همم
حصلت يعني موجوده عندنا احنا لكن اذا جاءت
بشكل مبكر يعني قبل خمس سنوات ممكن انقاذ
الحالات اذا خصوصا وجدت عنايه متكامله
منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله اليونيسيف
دقت جرس الخطا المنبهت الى ان تزايد اعداد
الاطفال المصابين بالتقزم في اليمن صار
ظاهره خطيره بسبب سوء التغذيه الذي يعاني
منه الاف الاطفال
وتسعى اليونيسف بمعيه حكومه اليمنيه
وشركاء محليين الى الحد من هذه الظاهره من
خلال حزمه من البرامج والمشاريع تعمل على
تنفيذها في ظل ظروف صعبه
من اوجه عده من خلال تقديم الخدمات
وعمليات التوثيق وجمع البيانات من اجل
تحديد ومراقبه البرامج لكننا نحتاج في
الوقت عينه لاعمال ملموسه على الارض ولذلك
نعمل الى جانب السلطات في اليمن من اجل
تقديم الدعم للعائلات
الحكومه بقطاعات المهمه وفي مقدمتها الصحه
والتربيه مع استمرار الحربي وتدهور الوضع
الاقتصادي والتجاربات السياسيه وهو عكس
سلبا على حياه الملايين من الاسر التي
اصبحت فقيده القدره على مواجهه متطلبات
الحياه